I'm still and us and I said this to you
before I'm still until you start filming
gambit I don't think and that exists a
new release date has been set but for
what I understand it's a different
version of gambit that you guys are
trying to make now then maybe the
version you were trying to make before
or am I wrong about them you are
absolutely right about that there are
elements that are similar but it is
different in tone almost in sub-genre
one of the things that we've done in
these standalone movies in hutch can
speak to this because he was much more
instrument than I was in Logan working
with Jim angle to hue on that movie
being a Western is that we tried to
create sort of subgenres within the
superhero genre when it comes to these
standalone
movies even Deadpool itself is like a
raunchy r-rated comedy not just a
superhero film so again that became
something different over the span of
developing it with Channing with his
partner Reid which I said where the
screenwriter and it is something that we
intend and hope to make but listen I'm
Jewish so my expectation for everything
is I don't believe anything until it's
out in movie theaters so I share your
cynicism generally but in this
particular case were working very hard
to get the movie I'm doing well from
what I understand the project that what
you guys were trying to get off the
ground was a heist movie and and now
it's a romantic comedy this still has
elements of a heist movie so it has
elements for rent a comedy and elements
of Iseman because he is a thief but it
is a love story between him and Bella